Travis Kelce the Chiefs tight end had
the weekend off after the Thursday night
win against Denver he joins us on behalf
of Old Spice the official sweat defense
of the NFL what did you do yesterday
Travis Dan how we doing I was at the
University of Cincinnati watching my my
Bearcats win a football game against
Tulsa and seeing us you know my Bearcat
teammates from the 2009 season where we
went undefeated in the regular season
man it was it was good to catch up with
everybody out there but I just want to
let you know that everybody here in
Kansas City I'm back here in Kansas City
now we're just we're all hoping and
praying that you get through these tough
times yeah come on over there that's
that's no fun man do you think that
Kansas City Chiefs fans more concerned
with my kidney stones or Patrick mahomes
knee you know Dan I Love You Man but
we're still we're still tallying the
other for you to where were you on that
quarterback sneak on the left side
trying to block von Miller which is
always a fun task I think would people
are don't understand is that that wasn't
on the bottom of the pile like screaming
in pain he was he felt a little
discomfort and was just kind of pointing
at his knee so nobody really knew what
was going on and why he couldn't get up
until you looked at his knee and his
knee didn't look like a knee I don't
know what it looked like but it sure as
heck wasn't a knee and and I'm just I'm
happy that the guy is healthy I mean I
kind of laugh about the situation and
how it all kind of unraveled in the
thought process that went through your
head through it all but I think the fact
that he's okay or they were just going
to be okay and back playing football
here sooner than later I think it's uh
it's definitely um it's definitely a
blessing you know and you never know
this game of football it's a crazy game
and you never know
what's gonna happen okay but is the play
cold in the huddle or does he does he
change the play when he gets to the line
of scrimmage it was definitely the play
call okay from the sidelines and I think
it's I don't want to say anything about
what anybody else says but you can't
blame a plain callin on someone's injury
and I think there's a lot of a little
bit of speculation that you know Coach
Reed knowing that he had a bum ankle it
shouldn't cause they shouldn't call that
once you're in the game you're in the
game it doesn't matter what you're
calling and then we knew we could get a
first down with a QB sneak which we did
it was just unfortunate at the bottom of
on the bottom of a pile that you know
that happened talking to Travis Kelce
the Chiefs tight end joining us Dan
Patrick show you know I don't know if it
helps you there's certain guys that
because they were overlooked whether
coming out of high school or the schools
that recruited you to go play football I
think you went to Cincinnati to play
quarterback originally but that chip on
your shoulder your thirty years of age
is that chip still there of nobody
thought I could play or didn't take me
seriously I feel like I mean I'm not
looking back on it there was a reason
why I was the University of Cincinnati I
wasn't really ready for to be able to go
somewhere big-time and fill in at
quarterback I think that Cincinnati
helped me grow and tell me you realize
that you know tight end might have been
the better option but I think you never
lose that chip on your shoulder I mean
you're always especially once I got to
the NFL yeah I've been trying to get
better and reach my peak performance on
the field and I feel like you're never
satisfied when you have that kind of
mindset it's just every single every
single week you're trying to improve
your game through your routines and and
and just be a better player and a better
teammate for the guys around you who's
the second best team in the AFC right
now
I would say man it's uh I haven't really
been looking leet why that had teams
I've kind of just been keeping it week
by weekend and our opponents but uh I
mean if you're looking at the records
it's right now it's New England us and I
believe Houston that are up even though
Houston just lost there's some
competition going on in the AFC right
now and then we're gonna have to keep
getting better as a team and and keep
rallying together you're in these these
games are you the emergency quarterback
for the Chiefs that's a good question
I'm not sure if it's me or Anthony
Sherman I think it's I think it's us too
just because of how a little bit more
experienced we are in this offensive
coach Reid does need to call a play
where I don't know neither one of us has
I've ever been back there at QB
practicing so I think it's he has just a
little bit more confidence in you going
out there than others when's the last
time you threw a pass in the game oh man
you're gonna bring this one up my only
time I've thrown a pass in an NFL game
two or three years ago but I remember
like it was yesterday when I saw that I
saw the Marcus Robinson running
scot-free on the sidelines and you know
I just if I didn't have the gloves on I
kind of blame it on the gloves I threw
it directly to the to the cover to
safety and in a ended in interception so
my only NFL has an interception but it
was a completion sorry to bring that
right yeah you got Aaron Rodgers on
Sunday night when's the last time you
asked for Jersey or an autograph of an
opposing team um that's a good question
I think the last one that I asked for
was George kiddo
I think I'm a huge fan of kiddo
who can't be right the guy's got an
unbelievable personality plays the game
with with so much passion and so much
love for his teammates when he when he
got to the league he I think he didn't
mentioned that that he had been watching
my game so that he could get better and
I had so much respect for him and just
just in him saying that and when we
played him I think it was last year two
years ago and I made sure that I I told
him he needs to get a Jersey to me yeah
he's been a he's quietly been a really
really good tight end and I don't know
what the hierarchy is now with Gronk out
of the game and I know that you felt
like you were the best tight end in the
game
and a lot of people do but who else is
up there Kittel is obviously up there
too yeah Zach Ertz without a doubt I
think Austin Hoover is making that yeah
him stride right now was with how he's
been playing it's kind of been
unfortunate that his team and it hasn't
been winning as much as you would hope
for with those kind of numbers man but I
think he's up there the young guy Mark
Andrews over in Baltimore looks
unbelievable the way he's been able to
put up numbers and that kind of that
style offense being accountable and that
style offense having to run block in and
get him get open in the secondary and
then the young guy Waller man Walters
Waller is making a name for himself over
there in Oakland and it's cool to see
you know young guys start to emerge in
their in their own respect what if
somebody said hey I I watched it when I
was growing up had a couple guys say
that to me and it's um it's weird it is
it is very
you're 30 yeah no but I still have that
kind of like old whenever I see Tony
Gonzales or Antonio Gates like I see
those guys and Shannon Sharpe I'm just
like me and I I kind of still look up to
you guys and then and everything that
you guys have done in the NFL so I still
have that kind of a young perspective
looking up it at the greats when uh when
I was a kid and um you know it's just
it's the ultimate honor man it's the
ultimate respect when you can have
someone come up and say that I saw a red
where you're in love so I'm guessing the
Old Spice that you're using is who's
working is that official that you're in
love oh yeah I've been in love with mr.
kalin Nicole for quite a long time she's
at least the past two years have been
been awesome engagement uh more than
likely coming soon sooner than later now
dog doo don't do the Christmas don't do
Christmas Christmas a bad move all right
sorry I'll wait till the next holiday or
just stay no no no no holiday no no you
get engaged on a regular Monday or don't
don't don't draw any attention because
love is everyday not just a holiday I'm
taking that advice with me for the rest
of my life I appreciate that
yes and congrats on the old spice stuff
you've been working with these guys for
quite some time
oh yeah I love working with Old Spice
over the years I've brought so many
products on the under this show a lone
man and this year we've got the new
sweat defense dry spray antiperspirant
and I add you get two full days 48 hours
of sweat and odor protection the the
official antiperspirant of the NFL and
if it's in every single locker room in
the NFL all 32 teams and needed to be in
yours you're gonna sweat when you get
engaged so I go maybe a double double
dose of Old Spice that day just hot and
sweaty guys so I'm throwing on even
though you get 48 hours of sweating odor
protection I'm throwing it all away
great to talk to you have fun against
the Packers and we'll catch up with you
if not during the season
certainly during the Super Bowl all
right big guy a straw over there with
yep you got going just know where Kansas
City is behind you all the way to you
thank you that's Travis Kelce for more
Dan Patrick show tune in to audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV stream for free
on BR live or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]